Oh, we're in the middle of an interview, sir.
Are you looking for reception?
No, I'm here for the interview.
You're what?
I'm Kit.
Oh yes, here you are, Kit Harington.
That rings a bell.
Game of Thrones?
Ah, Frodo.
What's Ian McKellen like then?
I think you might have me mistaken for someone else.
So, you're an actor then, what else have you been in?
I was in Testament of Youth and the new movie, Spooks.
I mean there's other stuff coming out in Hollywood and...
Why do you want to be the face of Mencap?
So, I want to be your ambassador...
...because I want to help support people with a learning disability.
I believe everyone deserves equal health care, equal education,...
...equal access to work, the same chances as everyone else,...
...to go out and have fun.